este domingo 7 de agosto toma posición
de su cargo el presidente electo de
colombia ha gustado petro en medio de
expectativas por como liderará el país
en medio de una fuerte escalada de
violencia por parte de los grupos al
margen de la ley en los últimos días se
ha conocido la intención de
organizaciones criminales y otros grupos
armados de sentarse con un nuevo
gobierno para así llegar a acuerdos de
paz con el tema la paz total petro
espera que este sea uno de los proyectos
más ambiciosos del nuevo ejecutivo pero
como deja el gobierno iván duque al país
en temas de seguridad que se lo
preguntamos a nuestro primer invitado
del día l jorge mantilla director de
conflicto de la fundación ideas para la
paz cientista político también conflicto
y crimen y seguridad gracias por estar
con nosotros en directo américa de
francia 24 jorge la pregunta inicial
como deja el presidente saliente iván
duque el país en materia de seguridad
buenos días gracias dejar una situación
muy compleja incremento de la violencia
en casi todas las formas asociadas al
conflicto armado no masacre es
desplazamiento forzado reclutamiento
de tal manera que el presidente entrante
gustavo petro recibe un país con una
crisis humanitaria y con un grave
problema de legitimidad del estado y de
la fuerza pública en diferentes zonas
del país cómo llegar a esta llamada paz
total por parte del ejecutivo que se
posesiona este próximo 7 de agosto en
colombia realmente es posible cuánto
tiempo de massa pudiera durar y qué
estrategias debe manejar el nuevo
gobierno de gustavo petro para llegar a
esta paz total si es que la logra es una
cosa que aún es incierta pas total en
este momento es mucho más una promesa y
una suerte de idea que aglutina a un
sector del país en torno a la
posibilidad de acabar tanto el conflicto
por ejemplo con grupos como lln como
someter o acoger a la ley a grupos como
el clan del golf una de las mayores
preocupaciones que hay en este momento
es que pareciera que la idea de paz
total no está conectada con una política
de seguridad sólida que contenga la
violencia que recupere el control
territorial
ustedes hay bastante escepticismo en la
medida en que son grupos complejos sobre
todo el caso del l en el caso del clan
del golfo no es claro un poco cuál va a
ser la relación entre las dos
conversaciones cuáles van a ser los
tiempos cuáles van a ser las condiciones
pero pues sin embargo en todo caso hay
que esperar que el precio nuevo
presidente se posicione y ver qué pasa
en los primeros 100 días que sin lugar a
dudas van a ser muy claves en términos
de cómo responda a esta oleada de
violencia que enfrenta el país jorge
como se pudieran manejar estas
conversaciones hablemos de los
principales donde está todo el mundo
mirando el foco puesto lln el clan del
golfo empezamos con él ln que es lo
principal que debe abordar con este
grupo en la delegación que manejará el
ejecutivo usado petro para llegar a un
acuerdo de paz
lo principal frente a lee leen es
entender que no es la misma guerrilla
que era hace cuatro años lln ha
evolucionado y se ha fortalecido en
términos militares y económicos sobre
todo por su presencia en la frontera
colombo-venezolana
pero también entender la necesidad de
establecer una agenda que sea acotada
que sea realista uno de los mayores
dificultades a la hora de negociar con
este grupo ha sido justamente que no es
claro su interés o su decisión digamos
de dejar las armas y por supuesto hay un
tema procedimental que es fundamental y
es que la comisión de paz de la ln está
en cuba
atrapada hace cuatro años
y ellos deben renovar su mandato de
negociación con el resto de las
estructuras que están en colombia y
asimismo deberían el nuevo presidente
cumplir los protocolos que firmó en su
momento con los países grandes como
noruega y cuba como lo haría exactamente
con el plan de calefones así empezar por
allí también claro el plan del golfo hay
una diferencia que es muy importante y
es que con el ln sería una negociación
digamos que el inicio del reconoce un
carácter político pero clan del golfo es
un grupo de crimen organizado es una de
las ideas más difíciles de pas total
digamos que el crimen organizado no le
interesa a participar en política
por tanto esa es una discusión mucho más
de sometimiento a la justicia o de
acogimiento a la justicia que será una
negociación pero con la fiscalía y no
propiamente con el ejecutivo lo más
difícil del clan del golfo es que
colombia no tiene muy claro cómo opera
el clan del golfo son diferentes grupos
son diferentes estructuras y en esa
medida son dos conversaciones
completamente diferentes vamos a un
escenario bien positivo supongamos que
el gobierno el presidente gustavo petro
puede alcanzar este llamado paz total
pero es que siempre también digamos
apago un fuego y nacen otros o sea cuál
es el problema estructural de colombia
para que estas estas organizaciones
criminales estas organizaciones al
margen de la ley ya definitivamente
dejen de existir estamos hablando
obviamente el narcotráfico cómo hacer
para acabarlo de raíz cómo hacer para
que estos grupos criminales no se
reinventen o nazcan otros es poco
probable que eso suceda sobre todo pues
porque américa latina tiene un problema
serio de crimen organizado digamos si
colombia superará el conflicto
tendría problemas como los que tienen
méxico o brasil o centroamérica
grupos de crimen organizado robustos
aquí lo que hay es un problema de
gestionar la amenaza de reducir los
niveles de violencia por supuesto si no
suceden transformaciones a nivel
territorial y la política de drogas va a
ser muy difícil eliminar esa oferta de
regulación violenta que hacen los grupos
entonces aquí hay un problema que por
supuesto se requiere negociación
sometimiento pero por eso insistimos
mucho en la necesidad de una política de
seguridad que pueda recobrar el control
territorial en muchas zonas del país
donde sencillamente no hay presencia del
estado o la presencia del estado es
bastante deficiente esa presencia del
estado en estos territorios que más
sufren la violencia se va a robustecer
digamos en este gobierno de gustavo
petro porque no fue así en el gobierno
de iu bando que falta voluntad política
desde luego hay un problema de voluntad
política sobre todo con el cumplimiento
de los acuerdos de paz con las farc que
tenían los componentes por ejemplo de
planes de desarrollo con enfoque
territorial
pero en todo caso gustavo petro recibió
un país con una situación fiscal
bastante difícil de llevar a cabo todos
sus programas sociales lo que plantean
términos de transformación de
territorios de inclusión social no va a
ser posible si no está mediado por que
se apruebe la reforma tributaria y
porque es colombia supere ese ese
problema fiscal aquí de todas maneras
hay otro otro tema que es central en
esta construcción local del estado y la
protección de líderes sociales los
líderes sociales son fundamentales para
la construcción de paz y para la
reducción de violencia y el gobierno
duque deja un país con un incremento
digamos histórico en términos del
asesinato de líderes sociales